uh because those games and franchises
like have it I mean I just uh surprised
my wife with the the Kingdom Hearts
vinyl so
um yeah stream is acting out so I got a
message from YouTube that the stream is
down Awesome YouTube that's great it
looks like it just decided to end when
we do a tough yeah
no problem we'll replay the street that
was interesting that is weird yeah all
right now it says finished okay
excellent connection all right YouTube
is bugging it's never happened I've
never seen that yeah I've never seen
that he's doing YouTube YouTube
[Music]
Master race got me
you want to tweaking I'll fix everything
else just
um end it and then start it on because
right now just keep going where you're
at oh no no no hold on it's saying it's
acting like it's back but yeah we're on
a new stream
while they got us so um again I said the
father she had before you had uh breath
of the wild you had Star Wars games you
had Halo you had inside and you had
Kingdom Hearts has anything changed from
that list
nothing like nothing I feel like those
are pretty solidified if I want to give
some honorable mentions you know I'm
playing through uh Mass Effect the
legendary edition
um love those games and it's been really
total really fun playing through those
again which one are you up to right now
which one I'm at three now oh good good
good
three which is really interesting is
uh I played through three but I got I
had won like a free PC copy and I was
playing on Xbox and I was gonna go play
it's like
I heard all this stuff about that ending
at that yeah all right I just gotta
played through this so I know what's
going on so I only played three in this
weird like fresh steak game nice
um so it's been really fun actually
finally doing the proper like one two
three and making all those decisions
with me through three and it's been like
pretty much back to back yeah yeah it's
been a completely different experience
and it's been great nice um but we doing
powder guard what we doing
Paragon Renegade as far as your choices
what are you leaning more right now I'm
playing I'm playing in the Paragon are
you playing Paragon okay okay
oh actually before that even though you
didn't finish you're doing one two three
oh which one so far is in the lead as
far as the the Mass Effect games which
one do you have is the better experience
if you had to rank them currently
especially specifically between one and
two
the specific name
if he didn't finish three no don't don't
don't leave the Witnesses on this way
okay my bad I was leading the witness so
one two one thing I will say you know in
terms of gameplay going immediately from
two to three it is amazing how much
better three feels moment-to-moment
gameplay
but if you had to rake it go to your
head which which one is the the best out
of the three which one would you choose
it's so tough because one and two
are so very different in terms of like
its structure like I love
the like the introductory of the world
of Mass Effect one and like exploring
these planets to like that fight with
sovereign
which one you got to pick one
I'm gonna have to uh if it's gonna be
between those I'm gonna have to go with
two my bad Patrick friend
Legend of encounter I'm an independent
Arbiter um I'm just watching
I may have influenced a certain decision
but he did it did on my mind Patrick
these are the droids you're looking for
the correct conclusion
I personally feel like three is the
better the best one but you couldn't
have
the anticipation with three without one
and two absolutely absolutely you can't
really and me and there's some degree
where you can't have two without one so
absolutely oh absolutely you you follow
the vine one's the best I guess
we got it I will say like that opening
the three is
yeah yes and like playing it now and
being like this was a 360 game bro they
were pushing this much it was so
ambitious for its time and then to think
about I should still to this day Patrick
no other game has really done that carry
the Save State yeah and choices and
decision into the next game that is so
ambitious you know and then to write
think about you have to write all these
branches that some people it will never
see right because of choice think about
how much development time that that was
truly an achievements
I remember you know what happened yeah
yeah I had two people I really liked and
at the end of three they maybe choose
between them yeah
I remember trying to
talk enough to where the the beat the
smoke doesn't happen and that's the
wrong thing and then they just he went
and then and stuff started goes like no
no we're not supposed
uh someone who did finish the legendary
edition last year and I think that was
the first game I finished that year uh
the thing that I made a specific point
to do as someone who had previously
played the first two games at least
three times four is I am looking up a
guy to uh get the perfect Mass Effect 2
ending because I was so annoyed yeah
yeah suicide mission and Galactic ready
everyone I everyone survived but like
one person at my Suicide Mission so one
of the things I played through the
ending and like you know prepared
perfectly and all this stuff and then
all of a sudden Morton was dead and I'm
like
I know exactly what happened yeah and I
look it up and it's just like oh yeah if
he's in this place he just has a high
chance of being dead yeah
I can't remember who it was but uh one
of the people that had like the little
blue Powers it's been so long since I
played it one of them stayed back and
saved everyone else and she died
so many possibilities yeah it was the
one with Samara and you can have her
killed and then have her evil sister
part of that like it's it's crazy but
salute salute to a mass effect and any
last final honorable mention in your top
five that that you wanted to mention
well that was the last one
for you Patrick was that the last
honorable mention no I mean the other
one is like the the current uh God of
War like Ragnarok was
man
is wanting to do this right now no I
mean you can see certain stuff I mean at
least in Survivor they have a whole jump
button
hey Google listen
I could see a little bit of The
Inspirations but y'all took it higher in
Jedi Survivor so I mean that's nice you
know you know stand on his shoulders so
you could be greater yeah oh my Lord
God Awards you got it in there you got
this serious no doubt though that final
question is for your favorite console of
all time why you had the Game Cube said
it was the most influence do you still
stand on that yeah I would definitely
still stand by that like that was such a
like pivotal moment in my childhood and
gaming career and like
it it took that step up from the PS1 and
64 graphics and and like gameplay
complexity in such an important way
that's Star Wars for it no yeah man and
it was 99
shout out to the GameCube pricing back
then but look man the absolute Legends
see your encounter designer which I can
keep correctly saying you notice I keep
thinking about you your Halo games and
stuff but I got a counter designer from
respawn entertainment the legendary
Patrick red back in the real man an
absolute pleasure thank you for taking
the time out of your day and then also
um just in general what do you want to
say to the people you know now that you
you kind of the team has crossed the
finish line and you didn't find words to
the to the realm as far as the uh Jedi
yeah well first of all thank you for
having me on it's always a pleasure
talking to you all about games and the
industry and stuff
um and for everyone like I just hope you
really enjoy the game you know if you're
holding out a bit I hope you can play it
really soon because I know I've already
seen like a lot of fixes going in so
nice
um but like yeah like we built this for
Star Wars fans and action adventure fans
and we know we want we want all of you
to enjoy it no doubt Lord addict and
also yes yeah hit up that new game plus
oh you gotta hit it we go hit up that
new game because we gotta have this
conversation that you keep hinting about
so we we definitely gonna get that new
game plus Lord adding any words to Lord
Patrick on his way out I appreciate you
coming on man
um you know it was it was a pleasure uh
I'm still I'm still playing you know
what's funny I'm like where I had to end
Jedi Survivor to come on the podcast
like you could ask uh Patrick is not the
greatest point to end so like my mind
won't leave that game right now yeah so
it's uh it's been a good game and I
really enjoyed I appreciate you for
coming on uh you know letting us bounce
some questions off of you uh you know
I'm sure the performance thing was a
little uh was a little anxiety written
for you a little bit so I appreciate you
getting through that no doubt no doubt
Lloyd King any final words for love
Patrick before he heads on to his date
well congratulations sir and actually
getting out that you know that Star Wars
game so you actually made it uh three
turn three times as a charm yeah yeah
um these encounters are so much fun uh
like I said it's still mind-boggling
looking at the game seeing a level
design uh all the work that you guys did
put into it and I'm so early on in the
game so I'm hopeful that the game will
definitely live up to all expectations
that I do have for it and um I'm just uh
thank you so much I do appreciate you
coming on today and I'm pretty sure that
your schedule is a little bit busy being
that the game just came out and
everybody's calling and bothering you
but fantastic game
um I'm loving everything about it so far
and I can't wait to see more of it so no
doubt no doubt and Lord Gondor of Lords
of gaming Dot
in the realm any final thoughts or
things you want to see the Lord Patrick
on his date on his way out
this is an excellent Star Wars game uh I
know I'm gonna be thinking a lot more
hours into it uh decent chunk of that
into the mini game that we were talking
about earlier and I'm about to look up
this baby games yeah oh you're about to
decide to do it yeah you are like after
I beat the game at least core gameplay
levels it's getting me hooked the way
that gwent once did oh strong praise no
so it's some form of card game
card game I I can promise you that that
again the legendary Lord Patrick rid of
respawn entertainment thank you so much
brother have a good one hopefully we see
you again soon in the round but always a
pleasure
what would be a Jedi the end Jedi Fallen
Jedi survivors no because that implies
that I've fallen and then he survived
after the fall now could be Jedi right
now
you all have a wonderful day
salute thank you so much for both of
y'all taking your time out of your day
for this much appreciated absolutely
talk to you guys later
now attic but you would do me a favor
start queuing up the super chats cause
uh I got him you got it here's the thing
guys um since we lost the last stream
and I have no clue what happened oh yeah
I don't have the members so if there's
any members that was in there which I
don't think there was I could only read
the super chats because those are the
ones that's actually showing up on the
uh we got five dollars food shot from
Robert kellett
blessed Sunday Lords since you have a
respawn Devon could you ask for them a
potential reason why it launched uh
rough on all platforms yes Roberts we'll
get riced into that
another two dollar Super Chat from
Roberts uh so who is getting King's
knees on the ABK being canned oh
afternoon fellas come get these hands in
guilty care and blaze blue
you see me on just send an invite I'll
knock you out anyway
make sure you see me driving down the
street I'll swing on you
five dollar screwdrop from Roberts You
Gonna Stand Down King the game has major
issues with frame rate and crashing on
consoles too so it's not just a master
race it is not on my car so I can't sit
there and talk about stuff that's not
happening to me so you're sitting there
telling me all right and listen I'm not
gonna scream for every PC dude because
from what I had all you PC dudes are
cheating anyway so oh my God you reap
what you sow second uh as far as the
concepts
for real right so as far as console go
your console's acting up blow into it a
little bit oh that's on the side maybe
you won't have a problem I haven't had
any frame rate issues I haven't had any
crashes haven't had any stutters I'm
playing on the series X sir and my TV
has vrr and all of her to help it do
what it gotta do so get off that TCL and
stop playing in that PlayStation 5 blow
out the back pause
continue
so um let me remember okay two dollar
Super Chat from Marvin Marvin ginyard
doing my part to the uh caravarian short
haired
episia all right no no let's let Kyle
read that um he had uh doing his he's
doing his part he said the two dollar
Super Chat for the short hair
um what is that oh well we talk about
red animals for this yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay that's the Super Chat I just posted
in there all right doing my part to the
Caribbean short hair alpaca
okay all right
we save it right every time y'all hit
the like button we save a random animal
five dollar Super Chat from Project
Aries nah I need some of that matte
designers on the team I need some names
of the map designers on the team
that's crazy messy we got a 20 super
trap from Jada oh God y'all know why I'm
here let's go switching my brothers and
that premium podcast of YouTube
knees please
why do you think you get knees were
y'all crying and begging you rap
snitches bro like you sitting here
talking about knees please you've been
packed your knees send them up and threw
them away y'all got six nine on your
face
all your Gunnies
gotta find out secrets from David long
uh have you guys seen the trailer for
The Blind uh assist feature on Forza to
help the blind play right now yes yes
yes Goosebumps hat off to the turn uh
turn ten yeah yo I saw it and he was
able to go around the track with no
problem that's crazy with no sight
that's absolutely crazy
then we have a two dollars to drop from
slow-mo let me make sure no one else
super jump of course slow mo no two
dollars super trap from slow-mo panel
are you a Jedi or a Sith I'm gonna be
row if you I know for a fact 100 fact if
I had four stabilities I'm gonna sit I
know for a fact well I'm not gonna even
say trying to front to you act like uh
the the force is definitely corrupting
me
there's no offense butts about that no
I'm gonna probably be uh uh I'll
probably be a great I'm gonna be uh
Force sensitive in the the the Sith if
if I couldn't if I had to pick one or
the other I would I would probably be
more evil than good and it would be like
like just petty stuff like not really
anything like what color would your
saber be pause but uh I I think I would
be more of a gray Jedi like in the
middle right it'd be great my my Sable
would be yellow okay
no yellow
[Music]
check right quick make sure you sounding
good sir
testing one two one two yeah everybody
doing can you hear me yes sounding good
sounding good sir before we get into the
main event and all that good stuff we
had a poll that actually remembered
to put in so last week poll results are
in the people have spoken to the
question with the latest statements by
Xbox regarding high five Russia's
success which do you think is the
measurement Microsoft is utilizing for
Success the winner of the four-way ILP
poll at 62 percent of the vote was user
engagement per title group coming in at
second at 25 of the vote was Game Pass
subscribers third place at seven percent
was the messy Lords I don't care these
games need to be fired and in last place
at four percent was the console and PC
game Sales Group shout out to all the
Lords who participated uh Lord King they
talking about using engagement man yeah
um that goes hand in hand with the game
pass so the more people that you're
having game pass the more engagement
that you should have I think that's been
there metrics that they're going through
I had a weird scary thought last night I
was playing in bed I had a weird scary
thoughts
that the series s is the main console
um
and the x is the anomaly and we're never
going to see uh the 12 teraflops or
whatever uh you know for the console
because
you know as much as I hated J dub and a
lot of the PlayStation dudes maybe right
because I think all the sales from the
series s
made it to de facto number one console
right because if the series X sold more
then that would be the de facto but
I say this right because
I'm looking at redfall at 30 frames per
second
and I'm like
little man is the problem yeah the
reason why his he's he's a he's
a victim of his own success
right the 30 frames per second is
because it was 60 frames on the box the
30 frames per second is we can get this
out to you in 30 frames per second let's
say it's a little man let's say a little
man is the issue right 30 30 frames
locked in will get you 60 frames later
the same way that we'll give you a
series X later like you can get a series
X later but you'll find little man's all
over the place
maybe little man is dictating the 30
frames error and continuing it to keep
that going and we'll send you a patch
later and they're seeing how many people
are in engaging on series x's and series
S's and if the number and disparity is
crazy let's say they have 15 million
um series uh S's and like eight to nine
million series X's then that the fact
that would be the series s it depends I
don't know what the splits are though I
don't know if the splits dictate that
there are more s's in the wild overall
out of the sales that's a good question
my my assumption it is that and then you
go into the the metrics of the um
engagement but if that is the de facto
console then you're going to be geared
to make sure that everything runs right
there and of course it will scale up on
the series X but there'll be an
afterthought that'll be the 60s uh
frames per second afterthought while the
main console itself let's get that out
the door at 30 frames and it's locked I
mean it's a good question I guess the
thing also we have to think about too is
one Studio Talent you know as far as all
students obviously not create equal and
then two as far as different you know
kind of what Lord Patrick alluded to
where there's different PC skus and a
lot of these games develop on PC first
and yeah a lot of these PC skews are
lower than the than the S so there's a
lot to unpack but we will get into them
to be fair though
mm-hmm I feel like even if that's the
case
um shame on Microsoft for promoting the
series X to the console and the way they
promoted it like you know monsters heat
for breakfast like they very was very
extra on promoting this on power so just
because the other one's selling more
it's like you're taking away from one to
give the other and it's not even good
it's like it's gonna stop the series
that's from selling so like you're
literally hurting the ex for no reason
because it's not going to stop him from
selling like yo it's interesting addict
do you think this in this thought right
that because of the the supply
constraints and the fact that they had
the foresight to make the S and the S
was probably a little bit more easier to
manufacture and get the chipsets and
everything out the door
because we had the supply constraints
and everything
they was probably pushing the X first
and then the S just took off by this uh
availability of the console compared to
the x
and now they were was forced to Pivot
and the S is probably the primary
because of what happened with the supply
constraints and the pandemic
it might be but at the same time
it's like to me you know if it makes
sense to them business-wise that's cool
but don't be doing that stuff because
I'll drop your platform in a heartbeat
if you start giving me mad 30 frame
games like I will drop it with the
quickness it will be straight down there
the game stop being traded in yeah it's
like you're not gonna sell me this
platform on the the hopes and dreams of
power but then stop let start uh what's
what I'm looking for stop not utilizing
it because more people are on the S you
know there's mad people that have like
the 40 series but it's not like they
stop trying to make sure that these
cards actually are used to that same
argument there's gonna be people that
still rock that 1070 like like me the
1070 TI you know that that may represent
the majority of of the base but they
don't stop supporting the 40 series no
of course but you may not be able to get
to maximize that for you but we gonna
move on from that one because I know I
know it's gonna
kind of funny
okay let me find out where slo-mo was we
got five dollars from Gary D Brown here
to save the Nebraska
tarmanian tiger love both my ex bones
and the PS5 is killing with the Dual
sense effects on General Survivor in
quality mode five dollars keep track
from normal people
where's R Kelly at we know this
lightsaber color yellow bee
wow yo I just caught that that's why
that was wild right there that's crazy
I'm gonna say that was a gifted Super
Chat like that was wild he said all that
in the characters you have for five
dollars
with the final scripture Kings on to
something the series s is the target
platform while the series X is the pro
console maybe that's why Microsoft
doesn't care about FPS I don't agree
with that one game doesn't make it out
one game does not make this a standard
it's an outliner the majority of the
games that has come out on the Xbox
series s and X have mainly been 30
frames especially on the X I mean 60
frames especially on the X I I feel like
the red fall has other circumstances has
nothing to do with what console sells
what and what this console says that
that's interesting uh so
70 percent at Series S and thirty
percent series X pink speaks nothing but
facts you know developers will focus on
the bigger install base
Series S is cheap and readily available
yeah that's what happened with the
PlayStation 4. that's why y'all got here
oh my Lord
drive by Joe when King takes the focus
he turns into a skinny boy
a what
um it will be you know and more than
likely it will be but you won't be able
to partake
you have a series X
hey King just straight up said it's easy
to hate from outside the club when you
can't get in Moving On Time One shots
moving
on topic double shots all right we're
gonna get into the side this debate
event that's why we are here uh yeah
this bitter black it's a bit of lack of
a report that's an understatement yeah
Microsoft Activision deal prevented to
protect Innovation and choice in cloud
gaming the CMA has prevented Microsoft's
proposed purchase of Activision over
concerns to deal with alter the future
of the fast growing cloud gaming Market
leading to reduced Innovation and less
choice for UK Gamers 100 years to come
so this hit the waves now I just want to
set it up before we open this up as far
as earlier in the week because prior you
know earlier the week we did hear shout
out to the New York Post that it wasn't
it felt like it was trending differently
initially and it basically said that
Microsoft Was preparing to close the
Activision deal despite um the FTC suit
you know as far as that is concerned so
leading into this there was an
assumption that the deal was looking
positive for Microsoft but as you do
know you know we did get that press
release from the CMA and here we are so
we got Lord K Asanti in the building
game in circle podcast in the building
we'll start with him first you know what
are your thoughts on the decision
provided you know and maybe you know as
far as the afterbath where does
Microsoft go from here so what are your
thoughts about this whole decision Cloud
being the blocker Not Call of Duty not
the PlayStation you know stating it with
horrible competition arguments
honestly for me so so before we even get
into this because it gets heated
it gets a little heated you
know people get emotional no uh so for
me
I always thought this was a like this
was a no-brainer basically because uh if
you look at the history of it if you see
the facts on the ground there the the
history is on their side right whether
you like it or you don't they have the
money to be able to make those purchase
purchases as long as it doesn't hit a
certain threshold which it did it
doesn't by the Merit of it you know
that's where it would be uh we initially
saw like me personally I wasn't the
hugest ABK guy uh my biggest my biggest
excitement for ABK was the the past
catalog right you know bringing it back
and all of that and hopefully letting
like great Studios like ravensoft and
others out
of the the sweatshops
about the Call of Duty you know the the
the the the the the minds let my people
go
the first thing I I did once I found out
this potential news was I played until
until uh Insomniac comes out with theirs
I played the greatest Wolverine game
ever made right by Raven software uh
Raven software who's right now currently
stuck in the salt mines
can't wait for him to come out you know
let's get it and yeah it it seems to
have ended up where it's ended up for me
uh honestly like as you know myself and
Mr ever born Saga we drink deep of these
documents and yes and these stories
ever born loves to to dig through the
details and and we enjoy that stuff from
from a very intellectual perspective hey
how does it how does this decision
process made and all of that early on
for me it seemed like
most of them most of the the regulatory
bodies were big Tech bad and they had
the answer and they were looking for the
the they were looking for for how they
can thread the needle to get to where
they've already they've already wanted
to go right
and it looks like it looks like the FTC
was kind of being a little too much task
really to use really really sad
arguments that everybody even the other
regulatory bodies was like sorry fam
this is not this is not the way to go
about it right they even had to step
away so that gave me hope that since
that's the case then it will force you
to go on the Merit of the case if if
it's to be blocked it's to be blocked
like you know some some people want the
the other the other company which I
won't say its name because they're never
born Saga would just pop up oh yeah you
already know
you know some people want this some
people want that I personally didn't
have a dog in the fight but it's an
interesting State of Affair where the
gaming would be if and when this thing
this this thing cleared right
after the CMAs report we've read all the
documentation like you know there's 400
pages of documentation they're still
we'll still be digging through that
thing for weeks you know after it's all
said and done for me it looks more like
they were still on the same page but
whereas the FTC was looking to to pin
something on Microsoft about well you
said you'd keep things uh open last time
and the other regulatory bodies had to
say no sorry that's not exactly what
they said it looks like they threaded a
different needle but still it kind of
still lives in that political realm and
not really on its merits right if you
want to cancel it because because
they're too big because they have an
outsized influence in the market all
these other reasons right say so Point
Blank but to put it to Cloud right it
was very it's a very wishy-washy
argument in a market that kind of
doesn't exist right now
exactly go talk to Google about how how
great that Market is right now you know
what I mean um even they themselves like
the part part of the documents uh part
of their findings for their concerns
that they were saying they pointed out
the fact that oh Microsoft did not offer
their subscriptions they didn't offer it
to a multi multi-service multi-game
subscription service right right now for
people who don't understand the
difference uh GeForce now for example
correct you own the game on Steam you
own the game someplace else you get
access to playing it in the cloud
multi-game subscription Subscription
Service would be your PlayStation
premium would be your Luna right right
but at the time
they sent they gave Microsoft what what
pong Soul likes to call a honey-do list
right that's where you heard the booster
oils
where did they pull all them out of yeah
they pulled them out of the actual
regulatory bodies like uh uh review
response to say hey these are your
potential uh competition that you are
going to be infringing upon right if we
allow you to do this so what did they do
okay check the list you get a deal you
get those deals everywhere so you feel
Microsoft did go off of The Playbook so
this is exactly CMA provided okay
provided exactly and and at that time
besides PlayStation who we already knew
refused to sign any deals right there
were no more subscription services there
were no multi-game subscription services
to actually give a deal to right right
literally a week later Luna went where
in the UK now
and that was the only other multi-game
Subscription Service besides PlayStation
that you could have given a deal to
right so you closed it you you cancel it
you say it's blocked and you say well we
have concerns because you didn't offer
to any multi-game Subscription Service
they didn't know what boostroid was
until you told them what booster egg was
if you wanted them to to to offer the
deal to a multi-game Subscription
Service you could have just picked one
and they would have done so there was
none there to be given at the time okay
so let me ask you for fairness for
fairness please yes you know so what do
you what do you say ksrt to you know
let's let's be fair in terms of
the Azure infrastructure backbone sure
sure and the reach that Microsoft has in
this space comparatively to others right
do you feel that also played a factor
into it and as well as you know what
Microsoft could have done is there
anything Additionally you feel Microsoft
could have done to appease that to make
Regulators say hey I know we're you know
big in the infrastructure space but
we're giving it to these 10 what else
could we they've done or maybe was an
oversight on their part that they may
have missed honestly what you're saying
there is exactly the point right they
block the deal in my estimation because
Microsoft has an outsize influence on
any Market that they are in right that's
the perception right they're they are
the big evil you know they are who they
are purported to be right that's that's
who they are right even though they try
to they move different these days they
don't move in that way at all but you
know what you're describing there of
them their potential influence their
Azure influence and all of that that is
all that that people saw but
unfortunately
you can't use that
to then block the deal because that's a
potential that has never that you don't
know will ever happen right it's it's it
is literally a side hustle and you're
literally like you're protecting the
side hustle at the expense of the game
that's what you're doing right so so
you're theoretically saying that they
could be it the fact that we don't know
that cloud gaming could or could not be
a dominant way in which media is
consumed your thought probably correct
me if I'm wrong your thought process is
by them being heavy-handed they're
potentially just killing Innovation when
Microsoft could drive and space that so
far doesn't exist I mean at the end of
the day how many any other how many
other uh startups can start a
subscription service at this level right
in in the United States we have this
thing uh this uh this thing I think it's
called title two where where all the the
the isps all the the cables that have
run on under the ground right you have
to let a competitor share it because
just because you Verizon were the ones
that laid that laid that cable for FiOS
doesn't mean you're the only one that
gets to use it right at some point since
it's everywhere now you have to share it
as if it's like uh uh as if it's what is
it essential infrastructure right so if
they really cared exactly if they really
cared about the future of of cloud they
could have made that exact situation
here where it's you have your Amazon you
have your your Azure you can say all
right you want to do this well you are
now essential uh essential Highway if
you will and you have to obviously uh uh
your competitors will hey you or
whatever but you have to share your
lanes of the highway so that others can
be there and innovate that's how you
bring that forward right everything they
did to get to the decision they've
gotten to actually to the point where
they they have actually infringed on all
those boostroids and those other Indies
that were potentially getting because
they wanted it they were like yo why
now they're like what's going on now
you're trying to protect you're trying
to protect the market but you you
inevitably basically made us lose what
we we had gained by all of us right it
doesn't look like they it doesn't look
like what they say their problem is is
actually what the problem was it's big
Tech bad Microsoft could potentially do
all of this they haven't watched
Microsoft you know uh completely grabbed
defeat from the jaws of Victory like a
million times but somehow you know they
could do this because they have the
potential I mean we could even go in the
technical the Deep technical realm yes
they have Azure but they're not actually
using Azure for their data centers for
for gaming they're literally putting
consoles in the cloud so like it's not
like oh we have software that can just
uh that can have an outsize influence
you want you want your stuff in our
Cloud making this up make a Soc that
will fit in our in our infrastructure
and we'll put it in there put it in that
is all potential that they could have a
path if they could have gone down and
you know what please I was just I was
just gonna say what irks me is it
clearly seems that even though the UK
the the EU did it in a better way they
threaded a different needle rather than
the mustache twirly thing
seriously it was ridiculous right it's
really that Harvey
competitions
with all that with all that said it
still looks like the CMA threaded their
own needle and reached the same
conclusion with the same kind of a weak
sauce argument I want it to be sound and
it's definitely not sound gotcha so
that's my only my own I hear what you go
for clarity you know
you you basically say like you use the
fiber example if they're you know
bringing that in we'll be like okay then
you have to regulate that with them so
that they open that up for everyone else
so this way for everything that's
concerned as far as Microsoft being this
dominant playing stream but because what
about the comments I don't know if you
caught those comments they said in
reference to like you know what we don't
want to it's so crazy that we don't want
to regulate or look at all these
different things or Cloud streaming as
far as from a governing standby I don't
know if you caught that verbiage yeah
they didn't want a government yeah
because it's a behavioral change rather
than a structural change behavioral
changes require someone to to to
actually pay attention and continue to
follow up on and make sure that that
they follow the the behavioral change
that they did and I mean let's be clear
here Microsoft put it in in contracts
contracts rule this space that's one
thing and they actually even offered to
create their own third-party uh Watchdog
company to watch them make sure this
gets done so it wasn't a situation of oh
well now the CMA has to come up with
their own regulatory body or they have
to pay for all this Microsoft said they
would pay for it themselves right all
you need to do is just let it be like I
want solid arguments and and and shout
out to to to game logic we had him on
the show Saturday yeah he's one of the
few folks on the internet that I hear
make sound arguments right but he's and
he's out there putting so much so much
thought and and and introspection into
into what he's saying and why he thinks
the dealer may be not good for consumers
or whatever
even even he says at the end of the day
the the argument that there was that was
made to get to get us to where we are
wasn't exactly what they were saying
right they can't say what they want to
say so they're just using something like
this to get us to where we want to be
which
I just find disappointing right you
wanna you wanna lock it down lock it
down say you're locking it down but be
real with it be clear with it rather
than using some kind of you know a
nascent Market that clearly just is not
it's not you know you're basically
saying that the needs of the few have to
outweigh the needs of the many here
which is just not the way we go about it
right that's the only disappointing part
fair fair enough fair enough great
analysis sir I'll follow back with you
some more questions but I gotta get the
realm in Lord addict the number one
Cloud streaming gamer here on the panel
um this was the reason it got blocked
attic I'm curious because you know from
all this prior you know it was like yo
Call of Duty's too big a game you know
you know Microsoft has too much control
as far as that is concerned those were
the initial arguments but the deal
actually doesn't get blocked because of
that it gets blocked because of cloud
what are your thoughts in general
I think after they stopped arguing over
Call of Duty they're okay this isn't
going nowhere let's argue over something
that actually can be relevant to
blocking this deal
um I don't
here's my thing like
to me
you're punishing Microsoft for setting
another industry forward
and they're using the industry that they
built
in another industry and I feel like
that's unfair uh to a point I understand
what they're coming from only in Call of
Duty and let's say they fix the latency
issues we don't know what they can do
with Call of Duty and you could be on
your phone one for one like that that is
a huge Advantage but
it's equivalent um I just personally
feel like the thing that just doesn't
make sense is none of this was ever
really talked about ever like this
entire time they kept talking about Call
of Duty they kept talking about this
they kept talking about mobile to that
they rarely talked about cloud and all
of a sudden over blocking because of
cloud it's just I feel like they they
were gonna block it regardless oh and
they wanted a reason oh that they could
say without the less backlash that they
could think of that's who I'm trying
I do think that
this still could hurt gaming going
forward but it's just a bunch of
speculation we we don't know about
anything but what I will say is let's go
I feel like them owning Activision would
have done better overall in the industry
because they they would undo the
sweatshops that make Call of Duty yeah I
mean ironically I think they would do
that I I just I just personally feel
like they get lashes to make cookies I
just all caught mines
I understand people's concerns but
Activision ain't really done nothing in
years
and until you start to hear that get
that that heat you don't really change
that look at EA EA trying to train try
to Cloud Chase in multiple different
ways and they even have one point where
they say we don't think single player
games have around uh have a space in
this industry anymore and now look what
they just released Survivor even though
you some people uh the game should have
launched in the condition it is the peak
of a single player game and it's just
like look like I don't agree with the
the announcement I don't agree with the
decision one thing I do agree stop
talking about it you know CMA you
canceled it come on FTC we don't have to
wait till May just say your decision now
we don't gotta wait till May we got the
big EU coming up
right there everyone just say one day
you know because I honestly do think
that
if the FTC and the EU uh approve it
Microsoft can
but if if the FTC or either or the EU
it's a dumb Block it's a rap like I
would say the odds of this getting
passed is like 10 15 right I I I just I
just don't see it happening because I
think it would be different if the FTC
wasn't already voicing concerns from the
start because you know some of these
lobbyists be doing we're crazy stuff and
uh they spending money well I mean
Microsoft's spending money on lobbies
too but apparently they're not paying
the right iron is good but um it's just
to me I'm at the point as a content
creator as a as a podcaster
as a regular consumer that that uh you
know that really keeps my ear to the
ground I want the dill over I don't care
if it passes if it doesn't pass three
more years
if there was uh if there was two roads
and on the left Road you have this gets
squashed now we never talk about this
again and in the right Row the right
Road this is talked about for three more
years and they eventually get it I'm
gonna take the left road every time
that right Road gives me a headache just
thinking about it okay you don't care
about the greater good for the consumers
no I don't I don't care about the great
I care about what I want and I can tell
you right now I don't care about 88 of
the catalog for Activision I've said
from the start this deal has done
nothing for me on the Xbox you don't
want them blizzards no I don't care look
OverWatch is free to play why is it mad
oh my God
I play Diablo 3 like four times my whole
life
and I played advanced warfare Call of
Duty Advanced Warfare for like two days
that's the longest I've ever played in
Call of Duty and that's all like this
deal has done zero for me that's why
well the moment this was announced I
made a tweet that says I ain't go live I
wish it was second because I don't care
about this video the sooner this deal is
over the better we can start going to
talk because I personally feel like this
deal has put an entire hole like so like
literally the industry pushed a pause on
the industry until this deal is over
because I think I think PlayStation
don't want to announce anything because
they don't want to see anything
everybody everybody's being like yo
don't show Too Much listen they just
came out the president just came out I
was like yeah we're giving 20 more money
to Acquisitions they they level of
disrespect is outside
I personally feel like you got third
parties that don't that want to announce
their game on on like a competitors
platform like Playstation or Xbox so
they gotta wait now because the other
two don't want to do anything but
despite a coincidence all these years
PlayStation has always had showcase but
last year it's not a coincidence in the
entire time we've ever done this
Microsoft has never come out in that
stage we're going to show you the game
for the next 12 months why because they
didn't want to show us to happen
they could they could have showed a
bunch of stuff but they chose to be
strategic in the next 12 months because
those announcements couldn't most likely
already announced
and they don't have to make themselves
look bigger than they want to be looked
at at the moment that's why PlayStation
was like yo we don't even want to have
an event and when PlayStation is is is
Iconic for announcing a game eight years
before it comes out
they got no problem doing it so
they did that there's like Wolverine 25
years later
you're out of control see but my point
is is all of these in my personal
opinion is because of this a b kill ABK
jail and I personally feel like the
remedy to our issues right now excluding
Microsoft not announcing anything or
showing anything Sony not doing their
own showcase so let's let's just cut the
APK deal out
you're blaming the reason why y'all
didn't get punished in 2029
just for clarity at what what if addicts
happiness about the deal with big block
if it continues to go go the way it's
going is that you know is is it is it
fair to say that you feel like because
Microsoft has so many resources so much
investment into this deal that it is
potentially taking their eye off the
ball at home as far as the things that
they kind of yeah and I personally I
personally feel like when it comes to
ABK Dell I don't care if it's blocked I
don't care if it goes through I want the
outcome that's quickest right so if if
it being blocked as quick kiss me doing
the block one if you're getting approved
happens next week we doing that okay I
don't want to talk about this for
another year Microsoft please don't go
to court yeah just just take away
your ball and walk home there you got
you got 90 Bill well probably not 90.
he's gonna lose something but that's
okay you got billions of dollars you
could put somewhere else but build your
own cars
quick question
saying like I hear you on that and by
and large I agree with you because I
feel like they've shown that they can't
walk and chew gum at the same time so if
you want to make me pick it's go go get
your house and order I feel you on that
but what about those who argue the point
that I don't care about those but listen
carefully listen carefully since this is
being decided on political grounds that
have no merit really right we can all I
think we can all by and large agree that
the excuse they used was weak sauce they
didn't want it to happen and that's what
they did right